hi welcome to this webinar on
camera-based non-contact health sensing
my name is daniel mcduff and i'm a
principal researcher at microsoft
research
i'll be presenting the first half of the
webinar and then i'll be joined by
shin liu from the university of
washington who will be presenting the
second part
which will be focusing on our latest
work to appear in europe's 2020.
during the webinar you can ask questions
through the text
q a widget on the website and we will be
answering those questions live through
the text chat
following the presentation we will be
doing voice
q a live where you can ask
questions in person and we can explain
any answers in more detail
so let me introduce the topic of this
presentation
first by framing it in uh
very uh relevant real world events
we are seeing um due to the the covid19
pandemic
that healthcare is transforming
one of the most obvious ways this is
happening
is a transition from in-person care
to telehealth and there's a couple of
reasons for this
telehealth has advantages as it enables
us to protect
healthcare providers and patients
it also helps reduce travel time and
expenditure
means that people need to take less time
off work they don't need to find child
care for their children
and and so it's in many ways preferable
many people have considered already
using
tele health or may many of you may have
already used telehealth services during
the pandemic
and this is something that's likely to
continue uh
even into the future because these
advantages
the cost savings and the protection
of both both patients and providers
is something that will be a continued
benefit
however some people have concerns over
how well
their condition can be diagnosed or
treated
when their only interaction with a
healthcare provider is over
a telehealth platform one of the reasons
for this is it's often very difficult to
objectively measure the state of a
patient
and what i'll be talking about
camera-based physiological measurement
can potentially be used as a way of
gathering these types of measurements
around the world telehealth is becoming
more attractive
and used at increasing rates
and one of the reasons for this is
because it can improve
the efficiency of healthcare by allowing
providers to see more patients more
easily
in addition to that it can actually
allow access to patients who need
specialists for their care but maybe
live
in remote locations or places where
there isn't many
specialists available one example of
this is cardiology
where telehealth has actually been
utilized
to a larger degree than many areas of
healthcare
cardiology relies on specialists who are
able to
analyze the cardiac
signals of patients and in many cases
there may not be a cardiologist that you
can easily reach
and so tele health has advantages to
improving access to care as well as
efficiency and cost savings associated
with that
in addition to telehealth camera based
non-contact measurement could be applied
in many other domains
baby monitoring or monitoring of infants
in the intensive care unit in a hospital
allow us to measure the state of an
infant without having to place
sticky uncomfortable electrodes onto
their bodies
in some cases babies can even get
infections from these electrodes
and so having a camera-based non-contact
measurement technique could
really improve at the quality of care
in eldercare cameras could provide
access to measurement for people who may
be not able to travel
easily to a surgery or or a healthcare
provider
and enable more easy and higher quality
telehealth visits
in chronic disease measurement
management and global health care
we could allow people to measure
physiological information more easily
more scalably without having to
rely on expensive
and often hard to obtain devices
so let me start by just introducing
the optical basis for these
methods where we're measuring the
physiological signals
from videos camera based measurement
relies on capturing
subtle changes in light reflected from
the body
which is modulated by both
pulsatile information or blood flow
and respiratory information or breathing
in and out as
light hits the body some of it's
absorbed
and some of it's reflected and picked up
by the camera
and the amount that's absorbed depends
on
these physiological processes so as the
blood flow in the skin changes
it changes the amount of light that's
absorbed or reflected from the skin
and the same as we breathe in and out it
changes the incident light
and the amount of light that is captured
by the camera
so we can actually use this principle in
order to extract
the physiological information from
a simple webcam video how this works
uh is um using an optical technique and
i'm going to use
schaefer's dichromatic reflection model
as a basis
uh for so grounding our computational
approaches
in the drm c here which you see on the
left of the top equation
is the rgb color
signals captured by the camera which is
a function of the luminance intensity or
the brightness of the light
in the environment and the specular and
diffuse reflections from the body
these specular and diffuse reflections
are changing over time
in part due to motion
or lighting changes or other things
but the diffuse reflection is changing
mostly
based on the underlying physiological
processes
the absorption of light
due to the volume of blood in the
surface of the skin
or the volume of the body during the
increase or
decrease of the respiration motion
we have a final component with this
which is the quantization error
which captures the camera noise
essentially
when we substitute in the three
equations at the bottom
into our drm equation
we end up with essentially a
mathematical model which relates
these physiological processes which are
varying over time
you see p of t highlighted in red and
the observed camera signal is c
of t we can simplify these equations a
little bit by making assumptions about
small components which can be
more or less ignored giving us a final
representation
and what's interesting is that p of t
the physiological processes
are actually a complex combination of
both blood flow
and respiration information so you'll
see in the final equation that p of t
is replaced by b of t and r of t
representing breathing and pulse
information
the reason this is true is
the principle of respiratory sinus
arrhythmia where we observe that heart
and lung function actually correlated
and they had their shared information in
the pulse and respiration signals
with rsa the interbeat intervals of the
heart are actually
synchronized with our breathing in and
out
and this correlation between these
physiological processes is useful
when we're looking at modeling them
computationally
we'll actually see later on when shin
presents
our latest work what we do is treat this
as a multitask learning
problem where we want to recover both
the respiration
and post information at the same time so
now let's talk about some of the
computational
techniques that are used for recovering
physiological information from videos
what you'll see on the left hand side
here is a video recorded of three people
and uh in this case we're extracting a
region of interest for each individual
around their face
and there's a couple of reasons for
choosing the face here
one is faces are relatively easy to
detect
and two the skin is exposed often
so they provide a good way of measuring
pulsatile information from the skin
we can't do this optical measurement of
post signals
through clothing for instance so we need
to be able to see
um the skin in the video
so for each region of interest what we
do
is separate the three color channels
captured by the camera so it's red green
and blue
and then for each frame of video we do a
spatial average
of those pixel channel information
and the reason we do a spatial average
here
is because each pixel is essentially a
noisy sensor each pixel captures
a bit of information about the
physiological change
but also a lot of noise due to the
camera quantization
as well as other variations happening in
the video such as head motions
and it's been well established that
quant camera quantization error in
particular
can be significantly reduced if we
average together
multiple pixels
so when we average these pixels for each
channel
and for each frame we end up with three
time varying
signals a red signal a green signal
and a blue signal these signals
each capture some information
about the physiological processes
whether that's
posts or heart rate or respiration
but they also each capture noise and
each channel because of their different
frequency sensitivity
captures different proportions of these
the signal and the noise and
so this sets us up for a very uh
traditional
signal separation problem we want to
find the underlying signal of interest
which in this case i'm going to use the
post signal or the heart rate signal as
an example and we want to separate that
from sources of noise due to motion or
lighting changes etc
so that signal separation here
is the main component for many of the
early approaches for doing camera based
physiological measurement
one example of this is independent
component analysis
independent component analysis involves
using assumptions such as the
periodicity
or non-gaussianity of the the
physiological signal
in order to extract that information
from
the observed red green and blue color
channel signals
there have been subsequent improvements
over these methods
uh one example using a chromium based
approach
and another using a plane orthogonal to
the skin
mapping in both cases
these advancements leverage more
information about the
optical and physiological properties of
the body
in order to improve how we demix the
physiological signals from the
distractors or the noise
however as with many domains of computer
vision
or applications of computer vision and
machine learning
simple signal processing techniques
often don't fully capture the complexity
of the spatial and temporal variations
that we're
observing in these videos so neural
approaches provide
a nice mechanism for learning more
complex representations of what's
happening
one of the first neural models for
approaching
camera-based physiological measurement
uses the following approach
so we take our input video which you see
on the left
and we have two different networks
the first of these networks you'll see
highlighted in green
is the appearance model the input to
this network
is the frame at time t
and what this network is
is therefore is in order to guide
a second network which you'll see
highlighted in black
which is the motion model and the motion
model has an
input which is the normalized difference
of subsequent frames so
the normalized difference between frame
t
plus one compared to the frame at time t
this motion representation you'll see is
essentially just
a set of pixels which reflect the change
in light from frame to frame picked up
by the camera
and doesn't have a lot of the
information about the skin
color or other information that we might
normally use
to segment the region of interest in the
video frame
and that's why the appearance model is
there to help guide
which regions of the motion model we
want to focus on
in order to extract our physiological
signal
so each of these networks has a fairly
standard
convolutional
network set of layers followed by a
fully connected layer
and the goal here is to predict
the post signal value at time
t or t plus one based on the input a
couple of frames so the input to this
model is just two frames
and the output is a single prediction of
the current pulse
signal value and then we run it
across all of the frames in the video to
get
the output pulse waveform
a nice component of this model is the
attention
mechanism that connects the appearance
and motion branches
what this does is essentially segment
the regions of the video that contain
strong pulsatile or respiration
information
and to most intents and purposes
that's skin segmentation because the
skin has
the strongest typically the strongest
pulsatile information
but also this the the
strength of that signal varies across
the face
and so the attention mechanism is
actually able to learn
some of those variations what you'll see
on this slide
is some examples of videos highlighting
the regions that the algorithm focuses
on
in order to extract the pulse
information from the video
you'll see that the yellow regions which
reflect high signal information
are in the forehead and on the cheeks
whereas the hair for instance or the
clothing
is dark blue which reflect that there's
very little
post information present
you also notice that regions that are
that have heavy shadow for instance
around the eyes
or below the nose also have
a a darker blue reflecting that
you know generally regions with brighter
luminance tend to have a stronger signal
that we can leverage to extract
the pulse information
another nice thing about these neural
models
is that we can actually do magnification
of these signals as well
so to help illustrate what we're
measuring here
on the left hand side you'll see a video
where we've magnified the post
information and you can see this color
change
in particular look at the forehead where
there's
it's easiest to see the pulsation or the
red
color change in in the skin
and that's what the camera is picking up
but it's been magnified several times
to help you see it
on the right hand side you'll see an
example where we're magnifying the
respiration information
look in particular at the shoulders of
the individual as they move up and down
as they breathe in and out and if you
pay particularly close attention you can
even see the nostrils
flare in and out as the individual
breathes
again these motions can be recovered by
the camera
and we've magnified them here to make
them easier to see
but generally speaking they're very
subtle signals
which is why we need to use
computational techniques to extract them
and boost
the signal-to-noise ratio
we have a couple of resources that might
be useful
if you are interested in investigating
some of the techniques
for doing camera based physiological
measurement
the first is the ipbg toolbox
which is matlab implementations of some
of the unsupervised signal processing
techniques that are used
uh for extracting pulse information from
videos
and also we've got a repo in including
our latest
deep neural network code which will be
presented in europe that the paper will
be presented in europe's 2020
which is a multitask efficient
convolutional attention architecture for
doing both
posts and respiration measurement from
videos
and i'm going to pass over to shin who's
going to walk you through that approach
and show more examples of the types
of physiological signals we can extract
from these videos giving some
demonstrations of
the types of signal to noise quality we
can get
even in the presence of in some cases
large head motions and other variations
within the videos
hello my name is shing i will be
presenting the second part of this
webinar so um um to
today's topics will be about the
multitask temporal shift
attention networks for on-device contact
class vital measurements
this is a paper accepted by europe's
2020 um
and it's a collaboration with uh joshua
automail
and shout out patel udub and danny
mcdove
i will start from the challenges on this
project while we start this project
the first one is camera based cardio
pulmonary measurement
is a highly privacy sensitive
application the data are personally
identifiable so those status are the
videos of
a patient's face with sensitive
physiological signals
and therefore streaming those data
or uploading any of those data to the
clouds to perform analysis or inferences
it's not ideal so so keeping all the
data
in local also avoid tons of regulatory
issues
you know the healthcare community and
the machine learning community are
all all pushing towards to this
direction the second one
is and this application requires ultra
fast speed to wrong device
uh people might curious why um
because because the contact sensor
usually runs at least
100 hertz or or two
250 six hertz and um
and you know if we want to make sure
that happened on device
we have to make sure our motor crew runs
around 250
fps 200 fps this is this is not
normal in on device machine learning
because
our own device object recognition or
or any other computer vision tasks they
usually require
30 fps and 60 fps and they can claim in
real time
but in our case we we do require ultra
fast at least 100
fps and and also
if if we can um run our model
on device for at least 100 fps we can
capture
the high availability her availability
is a key metric
in a lot of physiological measurement as
well as some mental
health is correlated with your stress
level so hrv
is a physiological phenomenon of
variations in the time
interval between the consecutive heart
beats in milliseconds so
in order to measure those variations in
in the in the milliseconds level
we do have to make sure our model runs
super super fast
um on some constrained device
and also um also if we can
um make this algorithm run on device we
can also enable some
very amazing optimistic sensings uh for
example if you look at your phone
and and and the phone camera can record
your face or while unlocking the phone
and also
manage your vital signals
moreover cameras can offer a scalable
measurement
imagine that in infinite centers on
or in some elderly service we can just
use the camera to remotely measure
everything you can really scale up the
physiological measurement especially
during the combine i think this is
really important
and our solution for that is we called
multi-task sample
shift attention network mtt skin so mgts
can
has a a a few features
i will start from the first one so the
first one
we efficiently learn the spatial
features
that maps from the raw rgb values to
latent representations
corresponding to the pulse and the
respiratory signals
um however this problem was not enough
because
there are tons of temporal noise uh
causing um the the neural network
harder to learn your spatial uh
information
and uh and physiological signals
so we also learned those temporal
features to
offset various knowledge such as hat
emotions ambient illumination
and changes for example if i'm shaking
my hands the
the light those illumination changes so
this could cause
a significant significant difference in
physiological uh
signals on your blocks so this is
something
that's really important um compared to
um the
2d cam which can only learn 2d spatial
maps
we want to learn both spatial and
temporal information
the second one is our network
can learn relationship between the
cardio and
raspberry systems so we leveraged a fact
called respiratory sinus arrhythmia
that daniel talked in the first part
where the lung and heart functions are
colorated
and therefore there's a shared
information in the pel's pbg or ecg and
respiration signals
and third one our system could work
in real time to support various
telemedicine deployments for example
it could it could work on your cell
phone it could work on other mobile
devices or on your computers
so i will i will start a little bit
background about
what is the temporal shifter module
because this is
a key components in our mdtsk network
so the rational behind of
temporal shifter module is very simple
so
the motivation behind of that is how
could we um
do something special to enable
temporal information exchange without
adding
too much computational overhead right so
so the tscm performs tensor shifting
before the tensor is fed into the
convolutional layer as visualized in the
figure
um so there um there are two positive
figures in
in the slice the figure a is the
original tensor without shifting this is
basically
an original tensor but it has a 4d
dimensions it has a four dimensions
though the y axis is temporal dimension
the axis is the channel dimension so
the tsm first splits the impotence
into three chunks across the channel
dimensions
uh i have to emphasize that for the
illustration the figure b
showing here um it doesn't split
into three trunks it splits
uh it supports the first channel as one
trunk and
and the second channel is the second
trunk and the rest of us the third trunk
but in real in in reality um
we simply this uh evenly into three
trunks for example if your impetus is
knight
uh has nine channels we simply the first
um chunk uh which has three channels the
second trunk has a second three channel
set and the third trunk has the
third three channels so after splitting
the original tension into three chunks
then shift the first chunk to the left
by one place advancing time by one
frame and then shift the second trunk
to and to the right by avoid from
delaying the time by one frame
so as as the figure
b illustrates it move the tensor
on the first channel down by one place
and
add a zero padding in the beginning and
the second shot can move the tensor up
to
by one place and add a padding zero at
the end
so and the both shifting operations
along the temporal axis
so that it can you can help
the temporal information got exchanged
and and both the shifting operations
along the temporal axis i i just want to
emphasize that
and the third chunk i remain unchanged
as shown
in the in the figure b the third channel
and and to the lost
channel remain unchanged and this is
worse
noting that tensor shifting does not add
any additional parameters to the network
as
as you as i described it basically is
shifting the tensor before it fed into
the convolutional network by enabling
information strength
among the labeling frameworks
so this is the figure
architecture figure about our purpose
network we call it multi-task temporal
strip detention network
mtts can mtt scan has two
branches motion branch and appearance
bench
i will start from the appearance branch
the appearance branch
is the real rgb value as we showed it
here
and the input size of the appearance
branch is 1 by 3 by 36 by 36
and it has four convolutional to these
operations and one average pooling
operations and in the second com come to
the operations
and the fourth uh complete operations it
generates
two attention masks for the motion
branch so in the motion branch
we took the normalized frame
uh with within two consecutive frames
so you will see the normalized frames
looks a little bit different
from the um regular
appearance frame because it's normalized
uh
frame and we add a tsm tensor shifting
module
on the convolutional 2ds in the motion
branch
and it's worth noting that in order to
best optimize the the latency in mtt
scan
we only compute the appearance branch by
once
and they generate the tension mask four
and
frames in the motion branch for example
if my batch size
is 20 the motion branch takes
20 by three by 36 by 36 as the inputs
it has 20 has 20 frames as inputs and
however
in the appearance bench we average those
20 frames
to a single frame and provided average
attention masks
to all those motion frames in the motion
branch
why are we doing this because
the rgb values do not change that much
especially within a short period of time
such as 20 frames or 10 frames
so that we can so we can save a lot of
computational power
in the appearance bench you know uh if
we compute
um the appearance branch by 20 times
uh you will uh use uh 20 times
four convolutional 2ds so it's a it's a
huge amount of
resource so um but in our case we
we have average frame and only outputs
attention mask at once
okay so after after we got some outputs
from the motion branch
we have two different branches for the
fully connected layer one fleet connect
layer is outputting
the respiration signal the other one is
outputting for respiration waveforms
and the people might be also wondering
why
attention mask is important here right
so
because after after the the tensor
shifting module
there's some extra noise i showed
in the figure below the architecture
figure so you can see before the tsm
you can briefly see a human face
but after tsm there's some extra noise
due to the
tensor shifting so by applying this
attention mask
you can help this network to learn much
better and focus on the regions that
contains
uh signals biosignals
people might be also curious is there
any other ways to perform spatial
temporal modeling
and the answer is yes 3d cnn is actually
well known for this
special temporal modelings right because
it takes a 4d
test as inputs and you can learn
temporal relationship
within within multiple frames
so we also propose a 3d cam
based on the existing state of our 2d
can to perform
the special temporal modeling however 3d
cans are super computationally expensive
if we adopt a 3d scene in both
appearance branch and motion branch
you'll be super computer expressive then
we think about
then we proposed another architecture
called a hybrid cam to cut out
the computation we had on on the
pyraminx bench so
like our mdts scan we
we use the average frame on the
appearance branch
as well as 2dc on the appearance bench
but we deploy the 3d scene on the motion
branch to learn
temporal relationship within the
certain window and this is a this is a
comparison
with the 3d can two hybrid can tscan
and and and 2d cam so you can definitely
see
the the computational difference
for example in the hybrid can there's a
there's a
there's a multiple cubes uh in the
in the hybrid can and in 3d can there's
a multiple cubes in both
motion branch and and pyramid expansion
however in the 2d can ts tscan
they're both based on the 2d cnns and
there are also some challenges when we
deploy
our mtt scan network in the
real deployments one of the main
challenges while deploying the old
device deep learning models
is the gap between the high-level graph
optimizations and
low-level operator optimizations on some
targeted platforms such as
raspberry pi or pixel 4 phones
or any other smartphones unfortunately
very few hand optimization tools are
designed to handle those highly
customized
neural network architectures right even
after an architecture has been
hand optimized for a target device
moving architecture architecture to a
new platform
or even changing the input shapes can
require some extra work
you know to change the optimized kernels
however
recent deployment compilers like tvm
has emerged to simplify this
optimization
process this compiles separate function
definitions from scheduling such as
how the code should be executed and this
separations
allows developers to quickly explore
schedule space without rewriting a
kernel to each step
so as we showed in the figure the tvm
takes
our network mdtscan
from tensorflow and it outputs a high
level uh differentiable ir they call
relay
and and and and auto tvm can generate
some customized kernels to some target
device uh in this work
we extend dvm to support mtt scan we
provide implementation of our network
um in in the tvm such as attention um
a tsm tensor shifting module uh to
enable the own device
deployments and optimization and low
level optimizations
okay so so here's our result compared to
the state of arts uh can oppose or trial
icas
we showed significantly improvements in
the pals
estimations about 43 percent improvement
compared to the
previous state of arts and also 3x
improvements on the signal noise ratio
and we're and we're going to show some
demos of how this mtt scan works in
reality
so this is the this is the video a demo
uh from the afl data sets
and you can see people are moving their
hats and
mtt scan and the mt hybrid can stream
range much better
uh uh waveform compared to the
previous one and this is the this is a
power
measurement demo from other data
datasets mmse
so you could also see the difference
between the
mcts scan versus the baseline we also
evaluate
our proposed network on respiration task
and we showed there's a 20 percent
improvements compared to previous
existing state fart can
here's the demo from afl on the
respiration estimation moreover
since our paper is about all device
measurements
we uh we implement our networks
and previous uh and previous uh state
fars
a 2d can previous 2d can
on on the tsm and test on our
low end arm cpu and it will show the
significant acceleration
one frame inference using mtts can only
take six milliseconds
uh compared with a tscan or hybrid can
it has even has significant
inference boost and this is also a
figure
compared with all the existing
architectures and our purpose
architectures
so the mtts can outperforms
all the existing architecture 2d can
2d can and and i will propose the hybrid
can the 3d can
i also like to talk a little bit about
the future work
of this remote uh uh whitehouse
monitoring current currently researchers
have
been pushing towards the pulse
estimation hrv
estimations respiration estimations and
atrial fibrillation estimations
and and a little bit about blood oxygen
sp2 estimations
however there there are also some
vital signs haven't been really explored
um
with a remote measurement like using
camera to measure blood pressure body
temperature and glucose
and hydrogen so we're all
very interesting to extend our current
work
to those new biosignals
from technical standpoints there are
also
a lot of challenges that still remain
unexplored for example
the network uh has some bias towards
some
skin tones that included in
the training data you know different
people with different skin tones
would demonstrate different
physiological signals and
uh we're very interesting how to use few
shots adaptations
to make a personalized model to do the
personalized adaptation
and as well as environmental adaptations
and secondly we're very interested in
investigating the multi
multi-modality physiological sensing
modern
smartphones includes um
not only the radar sorry uh not only the
rgb camera sensor but also some for
example rada sensors
or infrared camera sensors we're very
interesting
um a developer assistant to leverage all
those
different sensor modalities to make our
system more
more robust and thirdly since
uh our data collection requires you know
actual efforts to
get ground truth signals collecting
those data are not easy
so we're very interested in the factory
learning
uh scenarios you know how do we
collaboratively
learn and those on data
and create a more robust global model
and
and people can pull out those global
motor phone cloud and to
have a stronger personalized model on
device
and and the fourth one uh we're uh
teaming up with uw medical school to
to do uh different trials of clinical uh
evaluation such as icu evaluations you
know
how do we deploy em camera array on
on the icu room and uh monitor their
vital signs
and and please check out our github
repos there two github repos one of the
first points ippg toolbox
uh it's a it's based on matlab and uh it
supports various
uh baseline methods uh in this field and
uh we are
we also open source our mtt scan code
please fear to check it out
and uh just a reminder danny and i will
do a q a
live sessions after this talk
please feel free to ask any questions
you have
thank you
everyone my name is daniel mcduff and
i'm joined by
shin liu thank you very much for
attending this webinar and live q a
so over the next 15 minutes we're going
to be answering
questions submitted by the audience and
so we'll get started with that
some of these we've answered during the
text q a but we might answer
again to provide more details and you
can also continue to send in questions
and if we have time we'll try to answer
as many as many as we can
so starting off uh there were several
questions
uh like the an example from justin
who was asking about are there accuracy
differences due to things like facial
hair
or maybe makeup or other things that um
that could occlude the skin um or and or
kind of combining this with questions
about what if there's motions on the
face
like for instance blinking eye motions
talking mouth motions
um so shin would you like to answer that
question
yes yes so um i think that's a great
um yes that's true uh various
emotions can bring different uh motion
noise to
so however in our methods we leverage
the tension module
to automatically detect those regions
that contain
a physiological signals for example your
forehead or some of your skins
have more physiological sickness than
hairs or
like your clothes so um by doing
the attention module on top of the
convolutional layers
so we can we can automatically
uh make our networks to focus on those
important regions
um also since we use the average frame
in our
appearance bench and we only need to
compute this
attention mask every time frame which
can save a lot of computational
power so we can apply the sanitation
mask to all the
different motion frames
so that you can automatically offset a
lot of motion noise
so great okay thanks my answer for this
question and
there were several questions uh that
came in
related to uh whether skin type uh
affects this
the quality or the the accuracy which
with which we can measure physiological
signals so
thank you very much for those questions
and this is a very important
issue we do see that
skin types with greater melanin content
so typically darker skin types will
absorb more light and there will be less
light reflected so this impacts the
signal-to-noise ratio of the underlying
blood volume pulsed signal
it affects respiration less because for
respiration
we're typically measuring changes due to
motions of the body which are less
affected by the skin type
we have some published work on this
topic looking at performance
and there is also work looking at
performance of wearable
ppg measurement by skin
type as well so there's a few different
papers you can look at to see
how performance is impacted and this is
an area that we continue to do
research to understand how we can
mitigate
performance differences across different
people
jin another question that came in is
about
resolution and frame rate of the the
camera
uh do you mind saying a bit more about
what limitations there might be on that
yeah so uh those are great questions so
um
prior work have shown the 36x36 can
generate a robust performance and of
course
we can use larger resolution however uh
larger resolution leads to
worse uh latency performance for example
if you
input 100 by 100 frames to the network
it will significantly increase the
computational power so
what we did in our paper is we
downsampled
our original resolution to 36.36
and we have shown that this resolution
can lead to
about 100 fps so um
i saw there some audience also asked why
high frame rate is important in this
application um actually
if you if you use those contact sensors
like a oximeter they usually have at
least
um 200 hertz or or
or 100 hertz so the the ideal range of
frame rate should be 100 hertz to 256
hertz
so and in our people we have shown that
the mtt scan can can work
around 150 fps
so which which is ideal in a lot of
applications like a heart rate
availability
you know those um have to uh be able to
detect the fine
um uh peaks during the uh inference so
yeah that's my quite answering but the
question
thanks and this is also related
to the questions about how far from the
camera this signal
signal can be measured and these are
related because
ultimately it really depends on how many
pixels in your frame
contain skin because that's the region
of interest that we'll be measuring
the blood volume pulse from and so the
further away from the camera
not only is the intensity of reflected
light going to be weaker but also
there'll be less skin pixels present
using telephoto lenses people have
actually been able to measure the pulse
signal
at distances up to 40 meters
or even further than that with some
level of accuracy
that's with a very high quality lens
but in most of our work we focus on
using webcams
and and uh simpler cameras than that
and so in those cases we typically limit
the range to
maybe one to two meters maximum just
because you know if someone's holding a
cell phone or sitting in front of a
computer
then that's the sort of range that you
might expect them to be
at most in many cases they'll be even
closer than that
there were a couple of questions about
measuring downstream
signals from these measurements so can
you measure for instance
whether someone is in pain or can you
use these signals to capture
things like emotional changes and that
is
that that may be the case to measure
changes in heart rate and respiration
uh which occur with changes in emotional
state or or pain however
with just those signals you can't
measure those things
directly for instance some people
their physiological state may change
less
you know in a given situation even if
they experience the same amount of pain
so we just need to be careful that we
don't assume that
for instance increases in heart rate or
increases in respiration rate
due to one specific cause they could be
related to
lots of different changes so context is
quite important for interpreting those
shin there were a couple of questions
about comparing this
work to some work from mit
looking at using wi-fi signals
to measure heart rate and also
using eulerian video magnification
do you want to comment on those or would
you like me to
uh yes yeah you can comment on this i
can't i can add some simple comments on
this too so
um so in this work we focus on you know
leveraging some of the biggest device
around you to
detect the physiological thickness um a
smartphone is one of the most efficient
supplies around you so you can
you can actually use your phone cameras
to detect
uh your physiological signals and um
that's that's one of the main reasons we
want to make this
uh our our network to be around at least
100 fps and also generate
great performance uh danielle okay
continue to answer that
yeah that's great and and some of the
techniques we use in this work
could be applied to uh you know
perhaps signals from other modalities
like thermal
imaging but in the case for instance of
sensing via wi-fi they're using uh
different um techniques typically to
recover
the resp the the heart and respiration
rate
and these different modalities have
different trade-offs so
when measuring via wi-fi you can in
they've shown you can measure through
walls for instance of course
you can't do that with a camera however
the measurements from camera from the
camera often
more accurate than can be measured via
motion from
and and motions of the body captured via
wi-fi
so there are some trade-offs here and
just to comment on the
eulerian video magnification work that's
very
relevant and related but just to
distinguish this work from that
in the magnification work the assumption
is that you
know perhaps the the frequency of the
signal you want to magnify
whereas in this case we're actually
trying to recover that underlying
frequency
in order to get at the most accurate
measurements of
the underlying physiological state
include
like the heart rate and the respiration
so there are also several questions on
um
motions of of the body and lighting
changes in the environment
and those are good questions both of
those cause
noise in our measurement and so
our focus is on mitigating the effect of
that noise and boosting
the underlying physiological signal to
noise ratio
i would say on balance that motion and
and ambient lighting changes are
probably the two
biggest sources of noise in camera-based
measurement
at least that in the types of
applications that we see
currently which include your baby
monitoring
monitoring of people in um in hospitals
and also just general fitness
monitoring and tracking
shin do you want to comment just uh
briefly on
um the goals of of running on device
here
uh in particular how multitasking helps
yes so uh that's a great question so
official for
reality on device meaning um you don't
have to upload any of your data to the
cloud and
you know this is very important for a
privacy
concern um and um
and and uh in terms of multitask um
if you uh imagine if you need to do
pulse
and reservation um estimation
separately then you have to go through
the network twice right so then
computational time
will be doubled however if we use
multi-task learning at the same time
it can you can significantly reduce the
computational
time by half also uh
we leverage um uh effect called
arrhythmia that means the respiration
and telstra that some similar
information so we leverage this
physiological effect to to do the
multitask learning too
then do you want to add anything on top
of that
so i think that's a great yeah that's a
great summary so basically by sharing
parameters we can get
a a large improvement in the
the frame rate at which we can operate
rather than
essentially processing every frame twice
with two different networks
and i think that's the key we don't see
a large
improvement in in accuracy by using
multitasking
but i think there's some potential for
future work in that direction too
one question came from nina about
you know how the speed of measurement
affects the outcome
uh so if you're referring to frame rate
which was also a question
that several other people had about what
is the necessary frame rate
of a video for heart rate measurement
and respiration
rate measurement frame rate might be
could be as low as 20 or 30 frames per
second and your measurements could be
quite accurate
but for heart rate variability and for
measuring
uh more subtle changes in the waveform
dynamics
we would typically want a higher frame
rate than that which is why we focus on
efficiency in this work for instance
most contact sensors will measure at
maybe 256 hertz and
we want to try to get as close to that
as possible
at the moment our performance that we
report in this work is around 150 frames
per second
for the core network um
frame rate
um there were a couple of questions
about uh
about whether this can be done in
different settings
and one example is could this be done on
on for instance people who are running
uh in that case there would be a lot of
motion of the body so that
might make the current methods
uh not very accurate so for instance if
if the camera was mounted on a treadmill
you may get some accurate measurements
but there could be a lot of noise so
there still needs to be further
validation to really characterize
performance in a high motion
setting like on a treadmill but in more
stationary settings like when someone's
sitting at a computer
or when they're standing um still or
even if they were doing
a task that required less motion like
yoga
or other types of fitness activities i
think you
could measure quite accurately uh it's
just that
for instance rowing or or running might
have a lot
of body motion
uh there are a couple of questions about
additional
resources um shin do you want to just
uh mention the github repo that we have
for our current work
that's available for people to in the
links
yeah so um you can check out those links
uh one
one github link is for the ifes toolbox
um
this is a matlab script based
toolbox and you can use this toolbox to
to compute the magic from those
traditional singular processing
methods such as posts and you can also
go to the other link it's called mptscan
which includes the
training and the model architecture and
also our implementation of pvm
to support on the wise computation you
can
you can refer to this link to our
europe's paper
thanks jim so i think we have time for
one more question thank you to everyone
for all your questions and we'll try to
answer as many in the text
chat as possible but just to finish
off with with one uh question about uh
hyper or multi-spectral imaging so
this is a very interesting area of
research so in our work
we focused a lot on using just regular
rgb cameras
but if you do have the ability to
augment
the hardware so for instance if you
could have a camera with
additional frequency bands we've done
a little bit of work looking at
multi-spectral imaging using five band
cameras
in which case we can get better better
measurements because we have certain
bands that are tuned
specifically for the frequencies that
are have the strongest
physiological signal noise to ratio
and those typically occur around the
green channel so if you have green
and orange channels rather than
red instead of green and red then you
can actually get better performance
and the same would be true if you go
even further from the visible range for
instance if you went to far
infrared you start to get thermal
information so yes definitely multi or
hyper spectral cameras can
offer some benefit here but of course
they're less ubiquitous and they're more
expensive so
it's a trade-off in terms of whether
they could be used in certain
applications
so thank you everyone for attending this
webinar
the resource list has links to the
slides
to the github pages that shin mentioned
uh and also links to our project page
and to our
own personal web pages
please um please do download those
resources if you'll find them
useful and once again thank you for all
the questions and engagement
uh we uh we're really passionate about
this area of research
and would be happy to
follow up with as many questions as we
can
thank you